[Musica]
piero
[Applauso]
[Musica]
qualcuno ha bussato alla porta che ci a
berlino c'è qualcuno non c'è nessuno
troppi carità
ti ricordi diverte a disegnare e mega
che inizia è una sola e tanto ti troverò
devo subito avvisare vitale che l'api è
tornato era in studio lo avete visto ha
detto tanto non riuscirei a nasconderti
quindi meglio se troviamo subito un
nascondino dietro ma che i ragazzi sono
nascosta in un angolino dietro la
cassettiera ovviamente voi fate il tifo
per me e lasciate un bel mi piace sotto
questo video e se volete vedere altre
video nascondino o altri video paura mi
raccomando lasciate mai mi piace
mettetevi comodi prendete hip hop cori
iniziamo subito la challenge nascondino
[Musica]
per niente
nessuno mi devo ricordarti silenzio ma
penso che mi troverò qua in questo
angolino vedete un ascolto molto bene
eccolo
molto bello
di tale che cosa ci fai lì sta
nascondendo nascondendo non c'è tempo di
spiegarti adesso sprecati ball in studio
dove berlino visto però sul letto marino
ecco un bravo un bambino sensi lo so che
ti sembrerà super strano ma è tornato
zappi e come ha fatto tornare che
ricordi che l'ultima volta non era del
tutto scomparso forse colpa del
bombolaio non lo so con quello proprio
lì erano lì sopra il tavolo guarda era
proprio qui era seduto quale ha fatto
insomma la solita voce brutta e
fastidiosa abbiamo sbarazzarsene questa
volta una volta per tutte quindi
dobbiamo escogitare un piano prima che
torni anche a 67 mi sembrava
comprendendo versa questo punto su tre
però era solo spaventarti dell'atti mino
a berlino dimmi tu qualcosa dove
dobbiamo nasconderci adesso merlino per
le 12 fuori di andare fuori marino mi
raccomando protesici anche oggi tu che
sei la nostra guardia del corpo
il nostro caro e guardia del corpo
grazie per questi mazzini comunque
capisci che non c'è tempo
troppi il quale in casa da qualche parte
e noi dobbiamo trovare un nascondiglio
anzi prima dobbiamo trovare un piano per
liberarsene
avevi in mente qualcosa per liberarci di
slap e non lo so proviamo di invitarlo a
cena gli diamo di tutela che è una
bambola non mangia io penso che dobbiamo
innanzitutto prendere qualcosa per
difenderci quindi scegliamo un'arma per
difendersi ok io credo che è un'ottima
idea magari tu potresti prendere la
mazza per una pila perché a lui dà
fastidio la luce forte che è ottima idea
si procediamo così allora
con le nostre imprese lo so che sembra
strano una pila ma siccome gli dà
fastidio la luce potrebbe a cercarlo per
qualche secondo così avrei il tempo di
scappare però se non elaboriamo un piano
più concreto non riusciremo mai a
spararci di sla pipero merli delusioni
te che però ti ricordi la scatola che
non possiamo aprire in cui abbiamo messo
anche la maschera che non dovevamo mai
indossare la maschera maledetta
sì però non è una buona idea secondo me
è pericoloso buttarlo dentro almeno
sappiamo che scomparirà per sempre
dentro quella scatola se poi si mette la
maschera diventa doppiamente potente
sarebbe impossibile da sconfiggere in
quel caso ma lo sai che le cose più
mettiamola dentro scompaiono attiriamo
lo al piano di sotto e vicino alla
scatola e una volta che si avvicina di
tour.it rai un colpo di mazza e lo
butteremo dentro alla scatola
sì magari prima rocce che poi con la
mazza lo butto delle ferie vedere il si
sa che lui è molto furbo breve anche
molto lento a spostarsi e le nevi forse
possiamo riuscire per sta raffinando da
un momento all'altro
a berlino sarà il nostro asso nella
manica perché tra le nostre guardie del
corpo ci avvertirà stessa arrivando
qualcuno con il caso dal fiuto
infallibile e le sue orecchie dall'udito
infallibile senza per l'isola non so
dove saremmo adesso ora dobbiamo capire
dove nascondersi midollino mi sa che ci
sta già consegnando qualcosa guarda
sotto al letto
ok allora io mi nascondo dove mi sta
consigliando merlino cioè sotto al letto
ma che vive se tu puoi uscire fuori
dalla porta e fare la guardia alla porta
non vado subito allora se lui si
avvicina dobbiamo tirare anche lo di so
però mi raccomando che io vi nascondo
sotto al letto mi raccomando
per la guardia alla porta e avvisa lite
arriva qualcuno certo certo certo
berlino vieni con me perché non diamo
assistiamo esiste due berlino tranquillo
qui con me ne siamo qui ok a fare di
guardia alla porta
ok bravissimi sterili e credo sia le
scale e ora a prenderlo ok
speriamo che non facendo niente a vita
strano sento la sua presenza ma non
l'aveva richiesta dove sei adesso gli di
razioni di trick e un'esclusiva questo
passo sono questo controlliamo giuliano
o simili mi farò prendere desperate
detto difetto slavica ragazzi siamo
riusciti
ho azzeccato la p ciao berlino ma tu non
ti sei accorto di niente perché non mi
hai protetto dalla bambola parlante non
mi dire che stavi dormendo
questa è l'ora del tuo riposino ragazzi
snappy non c'è più devo averlo cercato
veramente ha funzionato meglio che tengo
la pila sempre con me si può sapere dove
rifinito e non dietro strappi cercato di
prenderlo dalle scale dalle scale avevo
sentito rumori e sono andato a vedere
che cosa fosse che cosa stesse facendo
veramente strappi era qui anzi mi ha
anche trovato o per fortuna avevo una
pila e lo accecato è una volta che li ho
montato una pila addosso è rimasto un po
stranito e ora è scomparsa brava sei
riuscito benissimo difendersi da solo
senza di aiuto
prima tu dovevi fare la guardia alla
porta dove si è sparito prima pensavo di
andare a prendere l'acqua appunto perché
avevo sentito il rumore sotto invece lui
era venuto qui mi ha ingannato e alla
fine che il rumore era non lo so forse
stato lui stesso a fare un rumore per
ingannarmi non ero né beh stiamo molto
attenti adesso perché penso che si sia
un po arrabbiato del foglio che lotto è
cauto è meglio che iniziamo subito ad
attuare il piano finale saliamo al piano
di sopra prepariamo la sua trappola per
rinchiuderlo dentro alla scatola si
mangia sia in tema di sopra
questa è l'arma segreta il teatrino
infatti lui è un burattino e quindi è
molto attirato dai teatrini e se vedete
i neutrini compare perché già successo
una volta vi ricordate
quindi noi metteremo in the three in qua
faremo in modo che lui compagna e poi
metterà la riva era pronto a colpirlo e
buie sarà nascosta sotto al letto con la
pizza facciamo vista abbiamo assolto
così mi terrò pronta nel caso che non
funziona il piano proverò ad accettarlo
e se funziona slam picano nella scatola
una volta che è gratuito che sarà qua a
richiudere la scatola per sempre così
potrà sparire per sempre nel culo
stagione eccola pronta
mi raccomando stai molto attento
la possessione quanto è pericolosa
questa scatola e posizionarla qui quindi
io qui non troviamo soprattutto chiedere
il momento miracolose ribaltabili mi
devi lasciarla passare che deve venire
questa nostra trappola ok ora che è
tutto pronto non ci resta che
nascondersi e aspettare che arrivi
troppi speriamo che arrivi e che cita
schio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
da queste tende
[Musica]
paziente sia più vasta piotto fitto
troppi lasciato un bel mi piace nuove
avventure paurosa stia me noi ora noi
andiamo a nascondere questa scatola come
sempre che nessuno dovrà mai a riaprire
fateci sapere quale in un momento che vi
è piaciuto più di brutta avventura o se
volete vivere altre avvenire assieme a
noi vi lasciamo 4 castelli cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
[Musica]